hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game you guys requested uh
from the Tata still India rapid Edition
it's a round three and it's a pregnant
versus Vincent kaimer and one of these
two gentlemen is leading the tournament
after the the first day but we have to
check out the game to see which one so
uh Prague as you know is currently
number 19 in the world's rating list if
you consider classical rating I don't uh
these are the uh rapid ratings but none
of them neither of them are playing uh
another of them plays that much uh rapid
tournaments to actually have a valid
rating so I think this is way way below
their actual playing strength uh and
Vincent is currently number 26 in the uh
world's uh classical rating list both of
them are 2700 plus players uh so let's
uh check out what happened here uh a
very exciting matchup frog has the white
pieces and he opened with Knight to F3
he went for the ready opening Knight to
F6 with G3 going for the king's Indian
attack and pawn to C5 with Bishop the G2
Knights the C6 and now Pawn to C4 and
pawn to D5 of course if your opponent
allows D5 you will always play it
regardless of the opening C captures
Knight captures and now Knight to C3 is
all been played before we have G6 and
queen to B3 putting pressure on the
Knight here and sorry about that arrow
and the usual uh move here is the just
uh the fan with Knight with Pawn to E6
or you can bring the Knight back to B6
but here we have Knight D to B for its
extremely rare they only been played a
handful of times and already here we
have a completely new game as A3 and
castles are known moves but here we have
Knight the E4 and it is now already as
of move 8 that we have a completely new
game so it's hard to say who is
surprising who here actually the point
is the Capron C5 and uh Vincent just
invited Bishop to G7 now puts pressure
on this long diagonal Knight Capricorn
C5 and now Queen to A5
and developing the queen with Tempo the
knife is attacked and there is really no
good Square for the Knight because the
queen is on B3 and you kind of don't
want to play Knights to D3 so Queen to
C4 to defend the Knight and prepare
Knight back to B3 B6 and now Knight to
B3 and here just Queen to A6 offering a
queen trade which is accepted but not
directly here we have Knight the E5 and
now Vincent trades on C4 if Knight
captures of course you capture the B for
night with the queen so Queen captures
and not Knight captures on C4 and the
bishop gets developed via Bishop to A6 a
story another Bishop A6 Bishop to E6 now
attacks the Knight again comes with
Tempo D3 defending the Knight and now
Rook the C8 we have castles and now Pawn
to B5 chasing away the Knight Knight the
E3 and here Vincent castles with Bishop
to D2 here praga has to give up a pawn
uh because there's just no good way to
develop the pawn it seems that Vincent
spawn sacrifice was um definitely
Justified fine and it's hard for proc to
get his bishop and the Rooks into the
game so he has to give back the pawn he
plays Bishop to D2 and okay Vincent
captures it Bishop captures on B2 with
Rook a to B1 and Bishop to G7 and okay
it's equal material but the one thing
that you can notice is that Vincent has
two uh pawns on the queen side product
has one which means that once pieces
started to get traded off pawns will
start marching down the board and at
some point uh Vincent will will have a
pass Pawn so Pawn to a three chases away
the Knight but now the Knight doesn't go
back and allow The Rook to enter the
game that would be great if that was an
option uh Vincent plays Knight to a to
stops Rook F to C1 and now prog has to
figure out how to do get the Knight away
from there the bishop simply will not
allow The Rook to attack it so for the
moment um uh you just ignore it Knight
to C5 goes after Vincent's bishop and
now Knights the D4 puts pressure on the
E to pawn with Knight captures on E6 and
F characters you could also capture with
the Knight to keep your Pawn structure
intact but it's better for the knights
to keep pressuring the E2 Pawn Rook fte1
defending and now Knights the C3 with a
double attack on the DuPont and also the
Rook on B1 is attacked so you have to
give up the bishop here and this means
that well once Bishop characters and
Rook captures now look at this pressure
the bishop here uh is uh you know just
ruling unrivaled and the pawns will now
start marching forward uh Vincent will
get a pass Pawn on the queen side and
the best way to counter this is spawn to
A4 it was not played by Prague A4 upon
captures and Rook to B4 this is the best
way to counter if A3 you put the Rook
behind the pass Pawn you capture an A7
and you minimize your casualties however
Rook to A1 was played by Frank and now
we have Pawn to A5 preparing Pawn to B4
with Bishop to E4 and now Pawn to A4 for
you you kind of want to also play B4 and
after Pawn captures play A3 because the
bishop covers the A1 Square you don't
want to have a pass B Pawn here here you
want to have the past a pawn Rook to A2
and now comes Rook F to C8 doubling up
on the C file King to G2 and now Bishop
to E5 with Rook e to A1 and now King to
G7 not even rushing with Bishop to D6
then put pressure on the pawn uh Ponte
H4 now uh this is basically admitting
you have no more moves so you're gonna
play H4 H5 to start creating some
weaknesses on the king side Bishop to D6
and now Pawn to H5 okay captures it and
now Knights the D1 for the lack of a
better move uh Rook the C2
uh because if you didn't go for this uh
Evanson would probably just go Rook to
C1 trade off the Rooks and then capture
the pawn on E2 so wrote captures in C2
Knight captures and C2 attacks then rook
and the A3 Pawn will now fall so Rook
day two Knight captures on A3 and now
Pawn to D4 we have Pawn to B4 uh the the
Pawn Stars marching forward even though
there was no need to rush this uh it's
uh okay it's a it's a very nice move for
a rapid game Knight to B2 uh going after
the A4 Pawn now and pawn to B3 attacking
The Rook while the Knight is defended
nicely by the bishop with Rook day one
and now Knight to B5 you have to give up
the A4 Pawn Knight captures an A4 and
now Knight captor Sandy for n okay you
are left with the pass B Pawn not as
great as the past a pawn as uh it's
gonna be a little bit harder to defend
the queening square as we do have a
light Square Bishop instead of the dark
Square Bishop instead of the light
Square bishop and here Rook to B1 the
only move that sort of keeps Prague in
the game he played Ponte E3 and now I'd
ask you to pause the video about the
winning move is literally the one you
are you are looking at now there I mean
it's it's very obvious and you guys are
looking at it now and of course the
Vincent played it so congratulations to
everyone Knights the C2 is the move that
wins the game point is that if you
capture with the bishop then just spawn
captures you cannot stop the pawn if you
play Rook to C1 then just Bishop to A3
and you give up here or if Rook to B1 as
was played in the game now comes the
real threat and that of course is Rook
C4 as the bishop and Knight are
undefended so you have to give up
material here again a capturing here
isn't much better because still your
Rook is attacked and the C1 is hanging
and after you play a rook A1 to let's
say defend the Knight you can just bring
your queen into the game and now the
Rook has the
uh be given up for for the uh for the
queen and of course you are now up a
full rook and completely winning so
after a rook to C4 Rook captures some B3
was played and now Vincent wins a full
piece Rook captures an E4 now Vincent is
up a full Bishop we have Knights the C3
of course Prague will still try to be a
little bit tricky about it as okay
Vincent does have two sets of doubled
pawns but of course he knows there's no
way in doing that Rook to B4 Rook
capture some B for uh sorry not Bishop
captures Knight captures on on B4 was
played uh we have Knight the E4 uh and
now Knights to D5 there's simply no
counter play here Knight to G5 and now
Knight to C7 you're basically your
editorial territory where you're just
waiting for your opponent to make a
mouse slip or to you know get
disconnected from the internet uh you
know King to H3 King to G6 Knight to F3
and now Knight to D5 fewer moves were
made Knight to D4 King to F7 uh Knight
to F3 and pawn to E5 and he was in this
position and move 48 that pregnant
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so uh pretty much
an a complete outplay from the from the
start a very nice opening very nice idea
everything started with the after prox
Queen to beat removed with this very
rare Knight beat the D4 like I said only
played five times before and probably
didn't figure out a way how to properly
play against this and you've seen how
how powerful this bishop was uh ever
since this uh Knight got the C3 and uh I
Prague was forced to give up the bishop
the bishop and G7 was just a completely
unrivaled he created a pass ball even
though it was not perfect play with
black uh those pawns could have been
pushed with greater Precision it was
enough as the position was just so good
yeah very nicely done by Vincent and a
very nice victory for him and also he's
one of the leaders after the first day
the second day has just started so I'm
gonna be watching if you guys have any
favorite games do use hashtag suggestion
and I will very gladly go over them so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank David
Kimura
festival.org.gg for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event until it finishes uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day